- You get really into
dressing up though, right?
- I do.
- I love it as well.
- Oh my God, yes.
- What's some of your favorite costumes?
What's some of your favorite done?
- Well, I kinda outdid
myself when I turned 50.
- Okay, wait. What? Wait, what?
- I know.
- Who?
- Be surprised. But no, I am 54 years old.
(crowd applauds)
So I am definitely a
woman of a certain age.
- I'm officially just
pissed off right now.
(crowd laughs)
I am 39 years old and
we look the same age.
What is happening?
I just need a minute for that to sink in.
I'm very upset. I'm gonna drink now, go.
- No, no, no, we have to finish.
- What did you dress up as?
- Okay, I dressed up as...
- The person who found
the fountain of youth?
(audience laughs)
- No, I actually dressed up
as 50 Cynt, like C Y N T.
- [Kelly] Aww, that's awesome.
- And I've always just been very, like,
transparent about my age, you know.
- I would be too if I looked like you.